what's up man uh not much
um just chilling on the way to
deliver a load of drive a truck for a
living but anyway
so colin because uh my wife has a
daughter from a previous marriage so
technically my stepdaughter
and uh we've been talking about trying
to get custody back we tried
a few years ago when she was three it
didn't work out
uh why did your wife lose custody
um it was a mixture of voluntary and
then just
uh uh like uh
i'm gonna go back to the beginning of
the story to try and keep my thoughts on
track otherwise i'm going to get
sidetracked
um well i mean did she have a did she
have an addiction problem was her abuse
in the home
oh no nothing like that um she just
signed over voluntary
custody of her child uh okay i heard
that uh
sorry i know it's cool man take a breath
dude you're good man you're good
what's up okay uh her
former mother-in-law started watching
her when she was about a year and a half
it was just before my wife and i got
together
and she asked my wife to sign papers
given her temporary temporary custody
just for legal purposes um
on the paper in colorado where cassie
lives
the paper asks for a thing it's got a
section that asks you for
how many hours the parents are going to
visit the child and her former
mother-in-law
put five hours just to start with
claiming it was legal purposes but that
she'd have access to the kid no matter
what
and then following that she started
following those five hours religiously
like it was five hours a week no more no
less for
pretty much the whole time my wife were
together and i were together until we
got married
so basically what you're saying is hold
on so what you're saying is
your stepdaughter's
grandmother
falsified documents tricked the mother
of
her granddaughter into signing papers
that she didn't fully get
that signed custody away of her daughter
limiting to five hours a week where a
mom could see her baby
yes and no uh her following the the
five hours religiously was part of it
but the documents were all legal and
everything like that that's not where
we lost custody uh flash forward about
uh flash forward about five months later
uh my wife and i we got married we
i've been driving truck the whole time
so we hadn't really gotten like proper
honeymoons or anything
so we decided well why don't you come on
the truck with me we'll go out for
just a little over a month we'll go to
galveston and see
my father-in-law because he lives down
in galveston and then we'll come back
right before christmas
and then we talked to her mother-in-law
and
asked if cassie could continue the
visits cassie is the daughter of his
name
but um asked if we could continue the
visits with
my mother-in-law and sister-in-law who
we were living with at the time
so that we could skype her and see her
and so that the visits wouldn't
keep the routine going two weeks later
when
my wife's grandma asked for a visit she
uh just paraphrasing the message mother
uh former mother-in-law sent the message
back saying i'm not obligated to get the
family visits they're not continuing
till colleen gets back
so we called her we were like all right
we're filing for
full custody we're going to court flash
forward another
seven months i want to say because her
and her attorney kept pushing it forward
and forward
finally around august we said all right
enough's enough but
in the couple month two months leading
up to that
everything fell apart for us my my
mother-in-law my wife's mother
relapsed on drugs she trashed the house
for
a considerable amount of time while she
was living with us
and then at the custody hold on hold on
this is like turning to jerry springer
brother
like let's let's let's reign this all
the way back in
okay no it's all good it's all good your
story's your story man
i'm uh it sounds like a mess okay
here's a mess and then some yes
so where i'm not tracking with you
is this
um i got a five-year-old little girl
you'd have to come through
hell and back to make it to where i
couldn't see my daughter
like i'm talking you have to shut down
the city of nashville to keep me out of
seeing my daughter and so something here
isn't doesn't pass my smell test there's
something weird going on here that why a
mother would sign over custody or some
sort of five hour rule or some sort of
hey thing and
i'm just going to take off for a month
and i'll just skype in with my daughter
none of that sounds right
and so i don't know the potential i
don't know the particulars of it and we
don't have time on this show to go all
the way back into it i just want you to
know that
there's something about that that
doesn't and i'm not super dad either
dude i'm just a regular guy
like something there sounds screwy
but fast forward to now now y'all are
circling back
and you want to regain custody
and how old is this little girl uh
she is seven currently and just a brief
little context this
uh a judge
turned the temporary custody thing into
full custody when we went to court
and over the last few years i'm not
gonna lie we have not been perfect
parents or
anything close to that we have had very
limited visitation and then trying to
circle back to
but listen a judge a judge only does
that a judge
only does that when they're like a judge
man i've been through so many situations
and walked alongside people who
i could not believe the judge gave them
back to their biological parents
but every judge i've ever seen their
bent is how do i get these families
reunited
so there was something there that the
judge looked at either your current wife
or that current situation and said nope
and i just can tell you my experience
has been there's something extreme there
there's something
really challenging going on in that home
for them not
for you've got a mother saying dude i
just want to be in my kid's life
that's the dream of every court i've
ever seen now i know every court is
perfect and there's idiots ever i get
that
but so now here you are seven seven
years later
and you're asking how do you loot how do
you
reinsert yourself into this daughter's
life
is that is that the ultimately when we
distill down is that the question
um yes and no we haven't necessarily
left her life
but she's growing up we're trying to
reconnect with her in a proper way
and see if custody can be an option a
few years down the road we're not trying
to go for a meeting or anything like
that we know that's not good for her but
okay
okay and is the custody for
the her best interest or is it because
you all miss your daughter and you want
to
start seeing her some more like why why
now
it's a little bit of both like we will
admit we've discussed it and if we
decide that
if going down this road we decide it's
in best interest for her to stay with
her
uh grandmother we will definitely make
that call because
we
we've never been fully out of her life
or anything like that we have regular
contact with her and everything like
that
um but hey i want you to hear how that
sounds to me
okay this is her mom
like my wife doesn't like to leave my
daughter like with the neighbor
for a few hours do you hear what i'm
saying
i don't feel like i don't feel like i'm
being super clear
um i get you you're working hard you're
a step dad
you are like in in life you were doing
the couple hours saying i get that
but your wife is this little girl's mom
does that make sense um is that register
yeah um so like are you wondering like
what my wife is struggling with
no no no no no i don't think that's a
that's a whole other show we can
that's a whole other call right um
ultimately here's what y'all are gonna
have to do you're gonna have to go to
court
or you're gonna have to get with a
lawyer or go see a judge and you're
gonna have to ask for an avenue back
and there's been some sort of behaviors
whether that's
addiction whether that's abandonment
whether it's neglect whether that's
just there's something there that
a court that is designed to reunify
families has said we're not doing that
in here
and i've never experienced it where
there's not a series of
services there's not a plan that a mom
and or a dad can work to reintroduce
themselves into the life of their child
i've never seen that it may exist in
your situation i've never seen it
unless parental rights are terminated
you're out
right you all aren't in that case
because you'll still get a few hours a
week or a month or whatever
but what i'm doing if i'm you the first
thing i'm doing
is i'm gonna go get a lawyer i'm gonna
get a judge i'm gonna ask them what is
i want to be in the life of this girl
and i think you and i could talk for
probably two hours or five hours
and i'd hear all kinds of stuff in the
story and there's probably blame to cast
everything mess to cast over i get that
but it's going to come back with you
looking at illegal somebody who
has taken away most of your custody if
not all of it
and saying i i'm gonna do whatever it
takes whatever
it takes to let that little girl know
that i love her more than life itself
and i've made some mistakes i haven't
been to use your words not haven't been
perfect
whatever that means um i'm gonna do
whatever it takes
and then you're gonna have to give
someone to give you a plan and you're
gonna have to exceed that plan
you're gonna have to go to all the
classes they tell you and you're gonna
take extra classes
you're going to send a letter a week
you're going to write letters let this
little girl
know how much she's loved and not so
much you but her
mother is going to write letters right
and you're going to um when you say
you're gonna show up you're gonna show
up you're gonna be early
and you're gonna drop off on time you're
gonna be respectful and dignified of her
living arrangement
you're gonna show up at all the school
meetings you're gonna show up you're
gonna show up you're gonna show up
and if you live in different towns like
we just can't do that right now
then this may not be the season for you
because you're going to have to convince
a judge
or a group of lawyers you have to
convince a judge
are you all screwed up and you're ready
to be make it whole
and i i can't wrap my
this is your daughter
everything in the world comes after that
everything everything
your wife's work your wife's plans your
wife's dating life your why
everything comes after that one thing
that's her little girl
and i'll burn it all down because i love
my daughter that much
so that's where you start start with a
judge start with a lawyer and say what's
my plan back
and you all work that plan you exceed
that plan but not just to get custody
you don't get close
no no you got a lot of healing for that
little girl
and you want that little girl to grow up
in a better situation than
she you want her kids to grow up in a
better situation than she did
and she's gonna have to know that her
mom values her
and that starts with a lot of
generational healing there man